Moskau Montag nach dem Putschversuch ein
arbeitsfreier Tag vorsichtshalber aus
Sicherheitsgründen kaum etwas deutet
noch darauf hin dass am Wochenende eine
schwer bewaffnete Söldnertruppe bis kurz
vor die Hauptstadt marschiert ist
nein ich habe keine Angst und fühle mich
sicher alles ist stabil ehrlich gesagt
versuche ich mich vor all dem zu
schützen denn wenn ich mich darauf
einlasse ändert das ja auch nichts außer
dass ich mir dann Sorgen mache große
Sorgen
das alles nach einem Tag zu Ende war ist
gut aber was in Wirklichkeit passiert
ist wissen wir nicht
am Abend meldet sich Wladimir Putin per
Video ich danke all unseren Truppen
Polizeibeamten und Spezialkräften die
sich den Aufständischen in den Weg
gestellt haben und treu geblieben sind
ihre Pflicht ihrem Eid und ihrem Volk
zum ersten Mal seit dem Putschversuch
auch eine Nachricht von wagner-chef
brigochin er rechtfertigt sich wo wann
und unter welchen Umständen die
audiobootschaft entstanden ist bleibt
allerdings unklar
Ziel unseres Maßes war die Auflösung der
Gruppe Wagner zu verhindern und
diejenigen zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen
die während der militärischen
spezialoperation massiv Fehler gemacht
haben
der Putschversuch auch Thema für die
NATO der Bundesverteidigungsminister in
Litauen wo gerade ein gemeinsames
Militärmanöver stattfindet 4000
Bundeswehr Streitkräfte will Deutschland
künftig dauerhaft in Litauen
stationieren
entscheidend ist aber dass ich natürlich
die baltischen Staaten und allen voran
Litauen hier große Sorgen machen die
Situation ist ohnehin angespannt und
gerade litauen ist besonders exponiert
und da ist es dann auch gut das zufällig
heute wir hier sind und diese Übung
stattfindet um deutlich zu machen
Deutschland die NATO stehen zu unseren
Alliierten hier an der ostfranke zu den
Entwicklungen im Ukraine Krieg meldete
Kiew gestern dass die gegen Offensive im
Süden und Osten des Landes erfolgreich
sei überraschend an der Front Präsident
silenski der Orden an die Truppen
verliehen
Erfolgsmeldungen also aus Kiew fragen
wir nach bei unserem Reporter daran
Präsident selensky hat in seiner
Ansprache am Abend gesagt dass die
Soldaten überall auf dem Vormarsch sein
und dass dies ein glücklicher Tag sei
wie viel Fortschritt macht die Offensive
der ukrainischen Armee der Zeit
ja besonders bemerkenswert ist es dass
es der ukrainischen Armee gelungen ist
gegenüber von herson auf der anderen
Seite des Flusses ein Brückenkopf zu
installieren wie gesichert der ist das
weiß ich jetzt noch nicht aber wenn dort
ukrainische Armeen einen Brücken die
ukrainische mehr einen Brückenkopf
errichten kann und mehr Truppen auf die
andere Seite in das russisch besetzte
Gebiet bringen kann dann könnten sie die
die schweren und gut gesicherten
Verteidigungsanlagen noch von einer
anderen Richtung aus angreifen auch
südlich von wolle da gab es Gebiete
gebietgewinner und dort waren auch die
größten und an den Seiten von bachmut
konnte die ukrainische Armee vorrücken
an den Flanken einige Ortschaften
einnehmen so dass eventuell eine
Einkreisung von bachmut irgendwann
denkbar wäre würde bachmut wieder in die
Hände der Ukraine fallen oder
zurückerobert werden dann wäre das
natürlich innenpolitisch äußerst brisant
für Russland
die Wagner sollten da sind
offensichtlich nicht mehr im Einsatz in
der Ukraine Putin hat ihm gesagt sie
sollen sich der russischen Armee
anschließen oder nach Belarus gehen was
weiß man da und was bedeutet diese
Ungewissheit für die ukrainische Seite
die Ungewissheit wo diese 25.000 Wagner
Soldaten die gut ausgebildet sind sich
befinden und wohin sie gehen würden das
beschäftigt hier jeden darüber
spekuliert man beim Bäcker aber
höchstwahrscheinlich auch im Generalstab
würden sie alle oder die Mehrheit nach
Belarus gehen droht von dort natürlich
eine potenzielle Gefahr das wieder ein
Angriff aus dem Norden auf die Ukraine
kommen könnte dass der drohen könnte
hier wieder angegriffen werden könnte
und das wäre natürlich ein großes
Problem für die Kräfte in der die in der
Offensive im Süden gebraucht werden aber
damals nichts weiß
denke ich dass man dort einfach jetzt
abwarten muss wie sich die einzelnen
Wagner Soldaten entscheiden aber die
Ukraine hat sich auf dieses Szenario
auch schon vorbereitet und
Verteidigungsanlagen gerade war an der
Grenze zu Belarus angelegt
das war unsere HD live aus Kiew vielen
Dank für deine Einschätzungen